nothing was ever said to John Bolten but
I have not seen him anything
I guess he's writing a book I have not
seen president Trump denying details
leaked to the New York Times about John
Bolton's upcoming book it's set for
release in March but shouldn't really
come out in an election year at all and
how damaging would that be to
relationships between future presidents
and their top staff especially the
National Security Advisor Fred flight's
has known john bolton for 30 years and
twice served as his chief of staff he
joins me right here in the studio
exclusively tonight Fred you're making a
pretty remarkable plea to John Bolton
tonight what is it well John's an old
friend and I I didn't take any pleasure
and write in his piece today but I
believe that the the concept that
presidents have to be able to confide in
their national security advisors and and
be able to knock around ideas this is
extremely important we want the
President to consult the best possible
advisors and know that whatever he
discusses with them isn't going to
appear in the press or in books so the
best thing here would be ambassador
Bolton to pull this book until mr. Trump
leaves office or at least until after
the election November there's a lot of
speculation today in Washington who
leaked this account of the transcript
people talking about individuals who vet
manuscripts at the NSC and a couple
names were floated on me and mentioned
them because we haven't confirmed it and
now there's people's it's a publisher
trying to hype the book before the book
goes on the market if it was someone in
the White House leaking this who vetted
it what were your thoughts on that B
well I take him back to Bolton and his
team at there were that they didn't leak
it but look sending something so
sensitive to the White House during an
impeachment hearing and all the
bureaucrats it would review and I'm
afraid it was an invitation for a leak
there's a report now that there were
many paper copies made in the National
Security Council if that's true heads
should roll on the NSC this should have
been very carefully pretty look that
doesn't excuse the decision to send it
to the NSC at all I mean you know I
consider Bolton a friend too and that
probably not as close to a friend of
yours but he's come on this show other
shows of mine for 20-plus years
he knows how this goes he's not a
neophyte he knows how this rolls in
Washington and he knows it's going to
get leaked
does he not I think it was a mistake to
send this to the NSC in the middle of an
impeachment trial I don't think he or
his staff leaked it they may have
assumed it would be handled very
carefully by the NSC I think that
decision was a mistake I think in the in
these circumstances a leak was very
likely Schumer seems to be very much in
the Bolton camp right now watch there
seems to be a giant cover-up among so
many of the leading people in the White
House if there was ever even a shred of
logic left to not hear witnesses and
review the documents mr. Bolton's book
just erased it Schumer Nadler Schiff all
poised to put john bolton on mount
rushmore of heroes in the modern
political age what does that say to
conservatives Republicans and others who
serve with him well the allegations
attributed to Bolton that the president
wanted investigations of the Biden's
aren't anything new I mean assuming that
that's true this was part of a
deliberation in the end that didn't
happen we want presence of throw around
ideas with their expert advisors I don't
know that the president held that
position frankly we know this is based
on anonymous leaks to the New York Times
we don't even know if these reports are
true this was a moment tonight in the
presentation by the defense team where
Pat Cipollone II talked about actually
shows from Saturday election
interference watch they're here to
perpetrate the most massive interference
in an election in American history and
we can't allow that to happen the
American people decide elections they
have one coming up in nine months for
all their talk of election interference
they are the ones perpetrating election
interference with this impeachment it
seems like the Democrats
worried that the American voter is going
to interfere with the election of the
next president see I mean if you listen
as it doesn't make any sense American
voter makes a decision and it just seems
like in the Democrats view unless a
Democrat is elected the election isn't
legitimate that something is wrong
that's not the where system supposed off
when's the last time you talked to
Bolton I talked him recently nothing so
you think you're really he's burning to
testify and he wants I'm not going to
comment on my private discussions with
with ambassador Bolton I'm just saying
that we had to respect the concept that
presidents have to be able to confide in
their advisors the best possible
advisors knock ideas around the
president can't be afraid that those
discussions could be leaked or published
so I think that I think mr. Bolton
really needs to withdraw this book Fred
we really appreciate you coming we
enjoyed your piece it was provocative
thank you so much for joining us